at first glance it looks like a typical
ad campaign featuring beautiful young
women but wait she's also beautiful but
she's not young to be exact
Helena Norwich is 82 years old and she's
one of the most sort of the models in
Poland
[Music]
fashion designer McHale geo bearlock
selected her he designs fashions for
celebrities and who created this dress
especially for Helena it was a risky
decision but one that's paid off
handsomely the risk was worth it we were
worried we didn't know what the reaction
to the campaign would be hello was also
concerned about how she'd look compared
to a young top model but the end result
is so enchanting delightful and
surprising that we're all happy with the
campaign
[Music]
this is Helena Norwich meeting with her
friend Ava she has so much to tell her
though her career began so late and so
suddenly she's now swamped with office
you look completely different here but
what's it like to pose alongside much
younger colleagues only once I thought
God I used to look like that actually
they should be thinking my god one day
I'm going to look like Helena so we're
even with younger models you see their
ambition not her kind of wisdom right
they're springtime the colorful autumn
and this music video shows that those in
the autumn of their lives still have
much to offer
[Music]
Helen Lochner ovitch is an actress and
has been one all her life she's
currently playing a countess in the play
hope sir or the boys it's about a
rebellion in a senior's home sometimes
the cast talks offstage about aging to
[Music]
Helena no ovitch remained still and
focused as her makeup is applied like a
true professional
Nawal [ __ ] has also gone through hard
times like when she was forced into
retirement by the managers at her former
theatre when I was 17 my last bosses
said I was too old to the theatre and
the younger colleagues were wanting
their turn on stage their chance to play
those roles for a decade no one showed
any interest in hiring her then came the
phone call which launched her second
career at age 18 I look at it this way I
give third ages hope that even at an
advanced age you can still live the way
you want to she's living proof that
someone in their eighties can be stylish
and cool
[Music]
recently the trend towards plastic
surgery and Botox injections has led to
people all looking much the same made of
plastic but fashion requires character
people who stay true to themselves and
are special somehow needs for civilian
that was magic she's physically fit to
but she's not happy with this shot the
light is wrong so she changed his
position and then we see what else 82
year old Helena Norwich and Lou
you